AJA HAMMERLY: Hello!
So this is Just
Enough Stackdriver
to Help You Sleep at Night.
Does everyone want to be here?
In the right room?
Awesome.
So I'm Aja.
I'm a Developer Advocate on
the Google Cloud Platform team.
But before Google, I worked in
a large variety of companies.
I worked at big companies.
I worked at
medium-sized companies.
I worked at a
early stage startup
through their GA for--
actually that was five years
through a couple releases.
I also worked in consulting
for a couple years, as well.
So I've had a lot of experience
doing a lot of different things
with operations at
different size companies
with different size-- with
different tech stacks.
So I'm going to set some
expectations up front.
This is an intro level talk.
I'm going to cover the
absolute basics of the tools
that I wish I had when one of
the many hats I was wearing
was, "Oh yeah.
You're doing the
Ops Engineering.
Oh, and you're QA Manager
and you're Release Manager.
Oh, and can you do a
little Dev work on the side
because we're really strapped?"
So we're going to
do the basics today.
As part of that job, at
the early stage start-up
especially, I had to
carry one of these.
Who's had to carry pager
or cell phone at some point
during their career?
C'mon.
Hands.
Yeah.
So to this day the sound
that our on-call phone made,
that ring tone, will
stop me mid-sentence
and I'll start doing this.
Trying to figure out oh, do
I have to deal with that?
Is that my phone going off?
Do I have to go make
sure the site's still up?
And I hate that.
I really hate the
fact that I still
have that visceral reaction.
And that happened because
we had a lot of alerts.
We had an awful lot of alerts
that didn't mean anything.
And so I'm really passionate
now about helping people set up
their applications so that
the alerts that they get
are the ones that matter.
But you get alerts when you
can take action about something
before it becomes a disaster.
Because I have restored
a database at 2:00 AM.
That was not fun.
And I also want to make
sure that no one has
to be woken up at night
unless something is actually
really wrong.
So one of the
things that happened
when I was working
at a startup was
we had a bunch of
different tools.
We had three different
monitoring systems.
We had a tool for
log aggregation.
We had another tool
for doing monitoring
of the product-- of the system.
We had tools for
debugging in production.
Not recommended.
And one of the things I
really like about Stackdriver
is that it does all of
those things for you.
There's one login and you
get all those features.
You have monitoring, you have
your logging, error reporting,
alerting.
And you have
tracing and it works
cross cloud, which is one
of the things I really like.
So if you're on Amazon
currently, moving to GCP,
you can have stuff
tracked in both places.
Maybe you've got
some systems in GCP
and some systems in another
provider, you can do that, too.
And because I'm here at I/O, I
need to tell you all flat out,
all the stuff is
currently in Beta.
So hopefully my demos will work.
So of all the apps I've worked
on, one of the big milestones
that went along with going
to production in some form,
whether that was our private
Beta, or our public Beta,
or actually
releasing, launching,
was we had a good
monitoring set up.
We had to know once people who
weren't our friends and family
were using our site.
We had to know that the site was
up and that, if it wasn't up,
we were going to
find out about it.
And when I was doing
this, I said earlier,
we had three monitoring systems.
We had a monitoring system
that worked on our Rail stack.
We had a monitoring
system that worked
on the system level and tracked
things like disk usage and CPU.
And then we had a
third monitoring system
that its only job
was to make sure
that the site was still up.
And it just pinged the site
every couple minutes, all day,
every day, and would alert
us if stuff went wrong.
But we didn't
write the best code
or I didn't write the best
code, let's just say that.
And sometimes we'd have a
really bad day on the internet.
And we'd have tons of
errors to be coming
from all different systems.
I would have no idea
what was actually wrong.
Did a bug in the Rails
app fill the disk up?
Or did the disk filling up
cause the Rails app to crash?
And with having all those
alerts in different systems,
it was really hard to get
a holistic picture of what
was going on with the site.
And so Stackdriver can do all
of those levels of monitoring.
Application level monitoring,
system level monitoring,
and drop-time checks.
About uptime checks, I always--
when I've been launching sites,
this is one of
first things we do.
And I always just set it
up to check simple URL.
Hey, is that still there?
Sometimes I have it
check to see if there's
specific text on the
bottom of the page.
Stackdriver does this great.
And of course, you can also do
things like check a given port.
You can check a
specific sub-path.
If you've got a--
perhaps you have
a microservices
architecture and you
have different sub-paths
or different paths
on your site that are served
by different applications that
are in parts of
your application,
you can check all
those independently.
And one of the
annoying things is
that I've found bugs
with these uptime checks.
I have found multiple bugs
at every single company I've
worked at with an uptime check.
From partner integrations
that went sideways
because someone updated
their API without telling us.
I found a disk that was full
and the system level monitoring
went sideways.
And so this is something I
really feel passionate about.
And I especially fell
passionate about the fact
that it's very,
very configurable.
So I can have as many of these
as I need to feel confident
when I'm monitoring a site.
And uptime checks
wouldn't be useful
if you couldn't get notified
when stuff went sideways.
So lots of different
ways to get notified.
You can get notified by email.
You can get notified by SMS.
If you use something
like PagerDuty,
that's supported, too.
You can also do Hipchat
or Slack or Campfire,
if you use one of those for your
group conversations already.
If you have the Google
Cloud Console mobile app,
you can get notified there.
And there's a web
hook, so if you
want to hook this into
another notification
system for your team,
you can do that as well.
So now we've got uptime
check, next step, I'm a Dev,
so what I care about is knowing,
is this awesome thing that I
built, is it actually working?
Preferably before the Ops
folks figure out that it's not.
So this is an application
level monitoring.
So I build a lot
of my stuff using
off-the-shelf and
open-source tools.
I use Node.
I use Rails.
I use Nginx.
I use Apache, Mongo,
MySQL, Postgres.
Done some stuff with RabbitMQ.
And all of these
things are supported.
If you have the
Monitoring Engine running
on your instance,
you change one config
file, you restart the agent, and
you magically get magically--
programmatically get support for
things like inserts, updates,
and deletes with MySQL, message
queue statuses with RabbitMQ.
You get responses-- you get
requests stats with the Nginx.
And all that's supported.
And turning it on literally
takes less than five minutes.
And even cooler, if
you're running in GCP,
running in Google
Cloud Platform,
we do some auto
discovery for you.
We check and see what ports
are open on your machine.
We check and see what
services are running.
And we can even look
at the instance name
and try to guess which
features you want.
I spun up a MySQL
cluster, you are going
to see in a couple more slides.
And I spun it up cross
Cloud into EC2 and GCP,
doing replication across.
And on the GCP side, it's
like, oh, you called this MySQL
and it's got the
MySQL daemon running,
so we're going to turn on
MySQL monitoring for you
so that you can pull in
stats on that automatically.
You don't actually
have to turn it on.
Lovely.
Wonderful, wonderful surprise
in getting the demo together.
But you remember thinking, hey,
my stack isn't on that list.
Great.
You can do custom
metrics and monitoring.
It's really straight forward.
There's great tutorials to
walk you through what format
you need to get stuff in.
And it will monitor
that for you.
And of course, since
this is Google I/O
and we're talking about
Google Cloud Platform,
there's integration for
Google Cloud Platform.
On App Engine, we pull a lot of
these things in automatically.
We did the same with
Container Engine.
On Compute Engine, we
do the auto discovery
I just talked about and
installing the engine
is very, very simple.
So I'm now on detecting
application errors, I hope.
I can also detect latency.
Every app I have
worked on, there's
been a couple end points.
But those were the health
check for the app for me.
If those are responding
quickly enough,
customers were going to
have a good experience.
And if those weren't
responding quickly,
I was going to start
getting phone calls.
And so you can do latency
monitoring on App Engine.
And one of the things I
really like about this
is that you can look
at the average, which
is what a lot of
other tools support,
but you can also look at the
95% case and the 5% case.
One particular app I worked
on, we ran 98% of our traffic
through one single URL.
And most of the time,
97ish percent of the time
it responded in less
than 100 milliseconds.
And it needed to.
That was really,
super important,
otherwise everything was
going to feel very laggy.
But one time or
two times in 100,
it would take up to a minute.
We knew why that was.
It was a particular Edge
case through the code.
And we decided it
wasn't worth fixing.
But those outliers were
pulling our latency stats way,
way down.
And so being able to
monitor the 95% case
would have been much
more helpful for me
trying, as the Ops
Engineer and the QA person,
trying to make sure that
we're doing the right thing.
And of course, if
you're using App Engine,
you can monitor either
your whole application
or just your modules.
And you can also monitor
by response time.
Maybe you don't care if
your error message just
take forever to render.
Or maybe you do want
your error messages
to render quickly because
you want to fail fast.
All of that you can
monitor your latency on.
So I've talked a lot about
application level monitoring,
system level monitoring.
This is the stuff that I
personally, sometimes think
is boring but necessary.
You have to have it.
You have to know if your
disks are filling up.
You have to know that you're
using your CPUs efficiently.
So, of course, you can.
You can monitor
disk usage and I/O.
You can monitor memory usage
and swap, CP usage and steal.
You can see what
your processes are
doing, how many are running,
sleeping, zombie processes.
You can monitor
your network traffic
and open TCP connections.
All of this stuff is available.
You can see it on the
dashboard, by default.
And this is all stuff
that you can set alerts up
on if you want, as well.
Some of these metrics are
only available by installing
the Monitoring Agent.
But the monitoring agent is
really simple to install.
I installed it on a bunch of
different servers this week
and in less than 10 minutes.
And who here users Chef, Puppet,
Ansible, one of those tools
to do the deployments?
You can also install with those.
There's instructions
on the website.
And I've already talked
about this a little bit,
but yeah, it works cross cloud.
So if you're in a
variety of environments,
you can have all of your
metrics come to one place, all
of your monitor into one place.
So you don't have to
manage multiple logins
to multiple services to see how
your whole system is running.
So I was talking a bit about
how certain things are monitored
and I mentioned
something about alerting,
but I didn't really get
into what that looks.
So certain things are
monitored, but no alerts
are set up by default.
But it's still useful
because you can see the
dashboards that we have set up
to check how your
system is doing.
And there are default
dashboards through services
like MySQL and NginX.
There are also
default dashboards
for things like App Engine,
Compute Engine, and Container
Engine.
And these are just our best
guess at what you want.
You can customize
them as you need
for your workflows,
your team, what's
interesting to you,
the particular errors
you know that your app has that
you want to keep an eye on.
All that is available to you
to monitor in different ways.
So here are some examples.
So in the center there is
the App Engine Response
Counterpoint Type, by code.
We have uptime checks.
On the left, you can see
there's a little green circle.
Maybe you can see.
And that's saying that
the uptime check has
passed in its most recent pass.
You see they have
different groups.
There's some information
about CPU and block storage.
At the very top, you can see
the current list of incidents.
Luckily there were none, so
it gave me a green check mark.
And here's a Container
Engine dashboard.
Looks largely the same, but you
can see the GKE Container CPU
usage on this one.
The GCE CPU usage
Container Engine
is built on Compute Engine.
Block Storage is also listed.
This particular
app doesn't use it,
but I've just shown you a
default dashboard off the--
what you get if you
just go straight
into monitoring after you've
launched your app on Google
Cloud.
So lots of interesting stuff.
We show this to you by default.
But that's not interesting
because I just showed you
static pictures of demos.
So let's actually
do the real demo.
This is the part where I
get to be slightly scared.
[DEEP BREATH]
So I want this tab.
So let's just look
and see what we get.
So this is for a MySQL cluster
replicated between AWS and GCP.
There's also App Engine
app running against it,
but they're not hooked together.
So I've got my CP usage
on both GCP and EC2.
You can see that I had some
incidents over the weekend that
are resolved.
That was as I was getting
these things set up.
And I can do things like
go here to Resources
and I can look at
the MySQL stats.
And so this is a
dashboard for MySQL.
It's showing me
some things here.
I've got a bunch more.
So you can see that I'm
in my two different zones.
And these two machines are
running in two different cloud
providers.
They're all listed together.
The health is all
there together.
I can see my stats on
all the machines, side
by side, just like they were
running with one cloud provider
and I was using that cloud
provider's native tool set.
And I want to share some of
the alerts I have set up,
just to really drive
home the kinds of things
that you can do.
So I've got three
different sets of alerts.
Each of these has two rules.
That's one for the GCP side
and one for the AWS side.
So the first one is
network monitoring.
So network traffic above a
threshold for 15 minutes,
that's one of them.
And I'm checking that
on both AWS and EC2.
There's a disk usage one.
If the disk usage is increasing
too quickly, I want an alert.
I don't want to
know when it's full,
I want to know when it's
heading towards full so I
can solve that problem
before it gets full.
And the last one is I'm also
tracking the MySQL inserts.
It happens to be that I'm not
actively inserting anything
to this database
right now, but if I
have a certain number
of inserts, either over
or under a threshold
for a period of time,
it will alert me.
So I can use the things
I know about my system
to figure out what the envelope
edges of my system are,
when I want to know when
things are going wrong.
And in all of those,
there's two rules.
The same alerting
policy happens.
And if I want to
do something cool,
I can show you--
I can edit these.
Maybe?
Yes.
Yea internet.
So here's the EC2 rule.
Here's the GCE rule.
I can add more
conditions, if I want.
I can change my
notification method.
And I can also include
some documentation,
which is something I really
like because I eventually
got-- finally got permission
to start passing off
application level
monitoring to the Dev team.
But sometimes they
would get an alert
and their first thing to
do was pick up the phone
and call me, because they
didn't know what to do.
And here I can put some hints.
Such as, if you get this
alert, try these commands.
These are the debugging
steps, go to this web
page on our internal site.
And once you've
exhausted those steps,
then you can pick up
the phone and escalate
to Level 2 support.
So that's awesome.
And you have some monitoring.
You're probably all
very excited about that.
But not actually all that
interesting in the long term
because that just tells you
when things are going wrong.
What if you want to know
about the current state
of your system right now.
That's where logging comes in.
Or you want to know
what's happened.
Maybe you want to know how
many purchases you've had,
or how many critical
errors you've had.
So again, cross cloud.
You can run this on AWS,
you can run this on EC2.
Sensing a theme here.
This agent, Blogging
Agent, is installed
on App Engine for you.
And you can install it on
any of our other services.
There is some support for
logging on Container Engine, as
well, out of the box.
And you could also use
Google Cloud Logging
API to stream events directly
from your application.
If there's particular
events that you
want that are in
your application,
you can stream those in.
I've done things like this
before to record purchases,
record chargebacks.
If we get into the
error handling code
and I'm handling
an exception, I'll
sometimes write out a bunch
of additional user state
into the logs at that point, and
then let the exception actually
cause the 500 error, just so
that I can have some better
idea of what's going on.
Once you have logs
in our system,
you can browse, query, and
filter them in a web interface
that I'll show you in a second.
And you might be thinking, well,
my issues are too complicated.
I have too many logs to
use the web interface.
That's great.
You can export it to BigQuery.
And BigQuery was designed
at Google for use
with filtering, aggregating,
and understanding logs.
So it's really,
really good at it.
If you know SQL, you
can use BigQuery.
It's amazing.
And it's really fast.
I've thrown lots and
lots of data at it before
and it goes very quickly.
So Logging demo.
Ha ha.
So one of the first
things I want to show you
is that you can
filter by log level.
So if I do any log level,
I have just a whole bunch
of regular long lines.
And this is largely pulling
from syslog right now,
but it's also pulling
from my application log.
The application here
is a Rails application
running on App Engine Flexible
Environment using our logging
gem that hooks you up
to Google Cloud Logging.
And I can filter here.
And I have a bunch of
stuff about a routing error
for a route that I apparently
have not implemented yet.
So I should probably fix that.
I can look at all sorts of logs.
I can look at a request log.
I'm going to do any
log level on that
because I don't think I have
any errors in the request log.
I can live stream logs
or I can pause logs.
I can look at a given date
in a given time period.
And you can look at a bunch
of our different services.
So if you're running a
bunch of different services
in the same project, you can
also filter by which service.
Whether you want App
Engine, you can do this.
You can also search, if you
have multiple App Engine apps.
You can look at your BigQuery
logs, Pos SQL logs, Compute
Engine, Container Engine, all of
that you can look at this way.
So the log processor
is really cool.
The other thing I was going
to show was-- Let's do this.
You can also search.
Pure text search.
So this is a bunch
of error-- things
that contain the string 500.
You can also do searches.
So there's a 200,
I can do searches.
Show matching events.
So show me all the
events that caused a 200.
Apparently there weren't any.
So lots of different things
you can do to slice and dice
logs with Google Cloud Logging.
So now you've got your logs.
You found that critical
error that I had there.
How do you deal with
that, especially if you
have a bad day on the internet?
So I've worked on two apps
that have DDoSed themselves.
I'm hoping that at least
one person in this room
has also had that
really, really bad day.
And our logs filled
up so fast that we
couldn't see what was going on.
It was just stack trace, after
stack trace, after stack trace.
And what we ended
up having to do
was spend two whole-- we
rebooted the entire system-- we
spent two whole days writing
scripts to parse those
logs so we could get
some idea of the errors.
And all we're doing is
aggregating the errors
very quickly.
And Stackdriver Error
Reporting will do that for you.
It analyzes your
logs as they come in
and it aggregates events and
groups them together based
on the stack trace,
based on the URL,
and based on the error
code they resulted in.
And then it keeps a
count of them for you.
So you've have 12 of
these and one of these
and, oh, this one's new.
Maybe you want to pay
attention to that one.
And every app I've
worked on has also
had some normal
errors through things
that just continuously
happen, even
if you're writing good code.
Or things you've
decided not to fix
and, when they're
all aggregated,
it's really easy for
you to just ignore
that as opposed to having
to see them in your logs
and see the stack traces
for them in your logs.
And one of the
things I really like
is it can also
proactively notify you.
So you get one new error,
it'll send you an email
or send an email to your team.
You get another new error or
another instance of that error,
it'll send you another email.
And yes, it does have
back-off built in
so it will not spam your
inbox if you're DDoSing
your site the way we did.
It will give you a couple
notifications, then
at that point, it's like
you know something's wrong,
go to the web page and
see what it looks like.
And again, for the
people who've had
a really bad day on the
internet, like I have a couple
times, there's
absolutely no limit
to the number of
errors it can store.
It stores the stack trace
for a couple examples
that you have enough
info to debug.
And after that, it just
keeps track of a count.
So if you're throwing
several thousand
or several million
errors, it's OK.
You're not going to take
Error Reporting down and lose
your tool that you need
exactly the moment you need it.
Setup.
So there's zero set up for
App Engine, zero set up
with most of the Stackdriver
Logging plug-ins.
It's a simple API call,
otherwise you can just call in
and say, hey I
just had an error,
hey, I just had an error,
hey, I just had an error.
And it will track those
and count those for you.
And we're going see
what this looks like.
So this time I have
an App Engine app
running in-- that's Debug.
There, that's Error Reporting.
So this is a Python
app Engine app
running in App Engine Classic,
not Flexible Environments.
And you see I've got
a basic error here.
I'm going to click on it.
It's a badly formed import.
So it's happened seven times.
I saw it in version one.
It was a 500 error.
It was first seen two days ago
and last seen two days ago.
So you've got some
basic info about when
it started happening, so
hopefully you can track that
to version or change.
Here's the graph
and here's a sample.
And there's a bunch
of different samples.
But I can also click here,
get some more information.
I can look at some raw data.
And thank you.
This is what I get for
not mirroring my screen.
And if that isn't
sufficient, you
can also go directly
into Stackdriver Logging
and see the request logs that
went along with that error.
So that you can debug
better and more efficiently.
So that's all in the log
information that went on.
You can see that it
was a critical error.
So Debugging.
You have an error,
you need to fix it.
And who here has debugged a
site in production before?
I'll own up to it.
Yeah.
I have totally hooked the Rails
console up to the production
database multiple times and I've
also caused people's browsers
to timeout because I threw a
breakpoint in on a production
website.
And I'm not proud of
this, but I have done it.
Enough if you raised
your hand that I
feel like I'm among friends.
So there is a better way.
We have a live debugger
in Stackdriver.
It doesn't add a significant
amount of latency,
around 10 milliseconds
is what they say,
and instead of actually letting
you step through the code,
it's setting a watchpoint.
And that watchpoint,
what that's doing,
is it's taking the status
of your application,
the variables, the call
stack, at a specific point,
and saying, here's
what was going
on at this moment for an
actual user on your website.
And frequently,
that's all I want.
Frequently, I'm doing print
line debugging on the live site
by throwing a whole
bunch of extra stuff
out to the logs
logs, when I can just
say, tell me what's
going on this line,
three lines before
the exception,
and then I can hopefully,
from that information,
figure out where I went wrong.
What went wrong on my site?
So in order to do that,
you're thinking, well,
how does it do that?
And how does it have
access to my source code?
There's a couple ways
you can hook it up.
You can point Cloud Debugger
at a Cloud Repository,
if you have that up there.
You can upload your
code to Cloud Debugger.
You can run it against
your local code,
which is what I've done
and that's awesome.
Or you can just say this file,
this line number and let it go.
You don't even have to use
the interactive interface
that they have.
So Languages and Platforms.
Right.
So this isn't in support
around all of our App Engine
languages, quite yet.
It's currently supported
in Java and Python,
for App Engine, App Engine
Flex, and Compute Engine.
Yes.
OK.
And Go applications
running on Compute Engine.
And support for
Node.js is in Alpha.
I know some people who've
used it, it looks really cool.
I haven't had a chance
to play with it yet
because I've been working
with Python and Rails.
So here's what this looks
like and if I have a couple
seconds, which it
looks like it I will,
I will try to do a demo.
It's a little bit
hard to demo this
because I can't make
things big enough
and still get everything
on the screen.
But the center there is my code.
On the right I have
my list of snapshots.
I set a watchpoint at
line 21 of main.py.
I can put a condition
or an expression
that I want evaluated.
If you've ever used an IDE
where you have your little watch
window, same idea.
And then underneath that
is the set of variables
that were active at that point.
And I can get the values
for all of those and also
my call stack.
And so I can see what
the call stack was
to get me to that point
I set the watch point at.
Maybe this won't be quite
enough to get you there,
but it hopefully will
at least be enough
that you can reproduce the
bug on your local environment
and actually fix it.
Or maybe you could
write the test
that you can then
use-- fix the test.
And you can fix things that way.
So some photo credits.
Yay for Creative Commons.
I want to thank you to all.
I have plenty of
time for questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]